wir haben ja in tübingen schon lange uns
vorgenommen unabhängig zu werden von öl
kohle und gas gar nicht weil ich tut
ihnen dabei gedacht hätte sondern weil
wir das klima schützen wollen unser ziel
ist bis 2030 komplett auf fossile
energieträger zu verzichten so hat es
der gemeinderat beschlossen und dabei
haben wir uns auch vorgenommen die stadt
nochmal umzugraben überall fernwärme zu
verlegen und diesen werden dann mit
erneuerbarer energie zu erzeugen also
wegzukommen von gas als brennstoff für
die sammler versorgung in der stadt
mittelfristziel sagen sie zum beispiel
eine große solaranlage die die wärme ins
netz einspeist oder was wir auch
vorhaben dass wir die wärme an der
kläranlage zurückgewinnen also endlich
wieder den weg habe heizen sondern die
abwärme aus der kläranlage aus dem
abwasser rausziehen und dann wieder
zurück speisen in die ferne werden da
kommen wir gut voran aber das dauert
natürlich noch ein bisschen bis man das
sieht und jetzt aktuell denke ich es
wäre nötig die möglichkeiten die heute
schon sind sich vom gas unabhängig zu
machen da bin ich die industrie
abgeschaltet werden musste oder putin
weiter geld von uns erhält schnell zu
nutzen und da gibt es eine möglichkeit
wir haben nämlich für unser
fernwärmenetz redundanz also doppelte
erzeugungs infrastruktur gekommen sowohl
mit erdgas
strom und fernwärme erzeugen sie mal was
heute als auch mit strom oder öl heizen
ihr könnt also das gas einfacher setzen
warum behandelt es noch nicht weil es
sehr viel teurer ist das heißt hier wäre
der bund war ich auf gefolgt den
kommunen viele kommunen solche optionen
die entsprechenden mehrkosten zu
ersetzen dann könnten wir ganz schnell
gas ob auch erheblich gut da hat
frau doktor kleiner würde ich sie direkt
einmal gerne fragen ist es denn sinnvoll
das schon wieder dann der staat
einspringt wieder der staat eigentlich
auch zahlt wie würden sie das modell
analysieren von der fall
also zunächst mal ist es richtig dass
wir uns unabhängig machen müssen von
fossilen energieträgern ich denke das
ziel teilen wir alle
[Musik]
überfraktionellen deutschen bundestag
nur gleichzeitig müssen wir eben
durchaus schauen wie wir mit dem
steuergeld umgehen denn wir haben jetzt
ja auch gerade über die ampel regierung
ein sehr teures sogenanntes
entlastungspaket für wurde eingebracht
das ist aus meiner sicht in der
beruhigungspille auf pump da wird wieder
ordentlich schulden gemacht
und ich bin mir nicht so sicher also für
mich hört sich das alles nicht
durchdacht an ich finde das toll dass
sie in tübingen diese lösungen haben und
die konzepte und ideen und für
deutschland wir sind ja die viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt ich glaube dann
müssten wir da noch mal ein bisschen ein
bisschen ganzheitlicher denkt man noch
mal ein bisschen anders die sache
angehen aber grundsätzlich finde ich das
gut dass sie auf kommunaler ebene da
kreative ideen einbringen
herr bruder wie sieht's denn aus sie
werden es schaffen ja mit der
energiewende mit putins gas der große
themen und natürlich an den kosten für
die bürger wir werden es nicht schaffen
übrigens nicht schaffen wir schaffen es
jetzt schon nicht schauen sie die
inflation ist bei 7 prozent angekommen
nachdem uns jahrelang gesagt wo der
erstens haben wir keine wenn wir eine
haben ganz wenig und sollte es mehr wert
und will sich zurück entwickeln so das
ist der preis den wir zahlen der zweite
preis ist der dass wir nur eine
abhängigkeit durch eine andere tauschen
ich weiß nicht ob es moralisch
höherwertig ist gas aus katar zu
beziehen statt aus russland so und das
dritte ist ja dass wir
wir also ich weiss nicht also das
virtuelle wir
kraftwerke in die luft gejagt haben die
intakt waren die vermutlich nicht
umweltschädlich waren sie mussten wissen
sie das hat mich sehr beeindruckt es
genügte nicht die abzuschalten die
mussten auch dem erdboden gleichgemacht
werden da ist etwas krankes dabei wissen
sie dass nur mit gewalt verhältnisse
verändern will die nicht verändert
werden können und ich finde das ganz
prima dass das wie man so was macht und
meine in tübingen auf island liegen
würde dann hätten sie geo werben dann
bräuchten sie eigentlich gar nichts dann
müssen sie nur paar liter benzin für die
autos importiert alles andere geht an
der begehung wärme aber ich glaube nicht
dass es in der stadt wie vor wolfsburg
oder irgendeine andere industriestadt
als beispiel dienen aber auch kommunale
lokaler ebene alle achtung sehr gut ich
werde trotzdem nicht
warum
gar nicht mehr länger sein
nein das ist eine andere geschichte nein
das ist schon okay finde ich ganz prima
ich bin für jeden grünen froh da etwas
macht was ihn in konflikt mit seiner
partei projekt und das schaffte jedes
mal herr palmer glauben sie das bringt
sie jetzt wieder in den konflikt mit der
partei das sehe ich doch bei dem plan
jetzt nicht und vor allem sie werden
doch jetzt auch oberbürgermeister zur
wahl antreten ohne die grünen
danach sieht es aber nein das halte ich
für ein konfliktthema mit meiner partei
ich würde gern auf den ökonomischen 100
noch mal eingehen weil den finde ich
sehr wichtig muss auch klar sehen den
uns das erdgas ausgeht weil putin hahn
abdreht oder du wirst du irgendwann doch
zu sanktionen greift die den import shop
bieten wir sie übrigens richtig finden
würde ich kann das nicht verstehen warum
wir diesen krieg jeden tag mit 200
millionen euro aus deutschland
finanzieren weil wir uns nicht von
diesem gasimport unabhängig machen
können dann dann ist es so immens viel
teurer als die differenz zwischen dem
erdgaspreis für die fernwärme in
tübingen und dem öl oder im strompreis
dass man aus kostengründen das unbedingt
machen müsste das ist so immens teuer
wir den tübingen die industrie nicht
mehr arbeiten kann weil sie kein erdgas
hat wenn der isaf zu machen was den
stahl werke schließen müssen da reden
wir von sich oder unter milliarden euro
schaden an der wirtschaft und hier geht
es darum das halt der preis für eine
kilowattstunde wärme dann irgendwie 20
oder 30 prozent steigen müsste und was
ich halt nicht machen kann als
aufsichtsratsvorsitzender stadtwerke
tübingen zu sagen den verlust tragen die
stadtwerke das ist bei uns nicht drin
aber das hat auch ein elementares
interesse diese schäden an der
volkswirtschaft zu vermeiden und der
könnte jetzt steht nun die differenz
absetzen und da geht es wirklich um viel
also bei uns ist das ein sechstel des
gasverbrauchs der das sofort ersetzt
werden könnte und viele städte haben
solche netze und solche
erzeugungsanlagen die also sofort
umschalten können auf einen anderen
energieträger bei einem wenn man das
ernst nimmt was wir alles hören jetzt
schon die vorstufe der gas krise
ausgerufen
also wenn ich so einfache möglichkeit
die uns fast nichts kostet und niemand
weh tut dass man sie nicht ungenutzt
lassen sollte japaner das mit dem fast
nichts kostet macht mich gleich sehr
skeptisch das war auch das versprechen
dass die energiewende jeden haushalt im
monat so viel kosten würde wie eine
kugel eis also wenn ich höre etwas
kostet nichts dann spüre ich mir gleich
die taschen zum eines web zwei jahren
und hat sich nicht nur eine partie fitzi
rung der gesellschaft durchgesetzt hier
ist eigentlich alles verstaatlicht
worden susanne gaschke vor zwei tagen
hervorragenden text in der welt gehabt
dass jedes problem mit in deutschland
mit geld zugedeckt wird egal was es ist
und den leuten die wenig verdienen ist
dann ein zuschuss versprochen wurden von
135 euro der wurde dann generös auf 300
euro erhöht und das ist ungefähr der
betrag um das einkommen von olaf scholz
zunimmt weil sich die abgeordneten
gerade wieder eine erhöhung ihrer diäten
erlaubt haben
ja ja
ja ja vielleicht vielleicht nicht für
alle aber jetzt jetzt möchte ich noch
mal eine ernsthafte frage stellen weil
sie weiß oder auf ein anderes themenfeld
ich habe keine idee ist es nicht
sinnvoll etwas mehr geld auszugeben für
öl und strom also erwägen die kohle zur
erzeugung fernwärme und damit die
industrie am laufen zu halten ist es
nicht ökonomisch sehr viel sinnvoller
als es jetzt zu verbrennen und daher die
industrie abzuschalten sie wissen zuerst
für die industrie ausgeschaltet hatten
das gas-kraftwerk sollte ja nicht
einfach so eine möglichkeit nutzen
unsere industrie weiter laufen ja sie
haben vollkommen recht nein ich bin
vollkommen ihre meinung außerdem ist es
nicht ein ökonomischer frage seit vier
wochen finde ich das unmoralisch in
einer beheizten wohnung zu leben wissen
wem wir dieser kuschelige wärme zu
verdanken hat also selbst wenn die
energiekosten und die heizungskosten
steigen würden wäre das schon sehr
bitter ein moralisches gebot der stunde
nachdem in dieser republik die 60 jahre
damit vertan wurden nie wieder zu rufen
und nachdem ein bekannter politiker
wegen auschwitz in die politik gegangen
ist vielleicht könnte
wegen neopor entschuldigung die stadt
ein dass er ist ja vielleicht könnte
jetzt wegen es aus der spd austreten
nein ich will damit sagen dass auch
moralisches verhalten nicht nur eine
frage des individuellen verhalten ist
sondern ist so was wie eine kollektive
moral gibt und sich jetzt von putin die
wärme liefern zu lassen um den preis
eines massenmordes ist ziemlich
unmoralisch
sie können jetzt ruhig zu stellen das
wiedersehen schaden ersetzt sind starke
worte ich habe aber noch einen anderen
punkt aufgeschnappt in der debatte den
ich über den tag hinaus und über das
konkrete thema hinaus interessant finde
nämlich die gesamtheitliche lösung die
sie gesagt haben ich glaube deutschland
wenn deutschland zugrunde geht geht es
zur grund an gesamtheitliche lösungen es
ist doch nichts besseres geben das ist
dass diese sehnsucht dass man eine sache
für alle gleich geregelt
es gibt doch nichts besseres als dass
ein bürgermeister der von seiner stadt
mehr versteht als jeder
andere von außerhalb einen vorschlag
entwickelt und um finanzhilfe bitten
das zu unterstützen als es nicht zu
unterstützen und zu sagen wir arbeiten
an einer gesamtheitlichen lösung und so
weiter die dann irgendwann fertig ist
wenn es viel zu spät ist das sieht man
aus meiner sicht in vielen
politikfeldern mein plädoyer wäre also
denen die ahnung haben nämlich denen vor
ort zuzuhören und wahrscheinlich wäre es
die beste antwort auf diese gaskrise und
dieses gas problem wenn man allen
bürgermeistern einfach sagen würde wir
zahlen deine rechnung die du mit deiner
neuen innovativen lösung für dein ort
geschaffen hast und der bund bezahlt ist
einfach das wäre kurz schnell hilfe
nicht gesamtheitlich aber am ende dann
noch für gesamtheitlicher weil alle was
davon hätten das finde ich sehr sehr es
ist fast programmatisch und
boris palmer hat ja das geschick die
bundespolitik mit punktuellen
vorschlägen die in sich absolut sinnhaft
sind sozusagen ein bisschen vor sich
herzutreiben und deshalb können viele
das auch nicht leiden weil sie in diesem
gesamtheitlichen festhängen das haben
idee dass da war sie noch die menge des
punktuellen viel besser als das eine
langdauernde am ende sowieso nicht
funktionierende gesamtheitliche also
insofern ein großes plädoyer
konkrete dinge konkret unter krenz ist
besser beenden als jetzt herr strunz mit
dem plädoyer für hertha auf ihr ja ja ja
ja ich gehe vollkommen rechnen am ende
würde diese art von politik weniger
kosten dass das geld das wir den taliban
nach geworfen haben das war vor kurzem
eine milliarde euro aber das kann nicht
passieren weil wir nur noch ganzheitlich
verhandeln und handeln wollen wir müssen
auch die flüchtlingskrise europäische
lösen das heißt wenn jetzt flüchtlinge
diese armen leute aus der ukraine müssen
sich jetzt und portugal gegen spanien
entscheiden